nichts gegen Spaß überhaupt nicht und
auch glaube ich dass die Summen über die
wir jetzt reden die sind geringer als
das Geld was wir bräuchten um diese
Investitionen zu finanzieren die
sicherlich wahnsinnig sinnvoll ist aber
das was mich jetzt umtreibt ist
sicherlich für den Spaß total gut den
junge Leute haben sollen ohne Frage wir
alle waren jung hatten viel Spaß aber
die Frage ist muss das eigentlich auf
Kosten des Steuerzahlers passieren da
sage ich ganz klar nein nein zu einem
stärker
ausufern denn Nanny Staat was passiert
ähm die Bundesregierung will
Jugendlichen oder jungen Erwachsene ab
18 Jahren im nächsten Jahr eine
Kulturkarte wird von 200 € schenken
jeder 18-Jährige soll die bekommen soll
damit Museen gehen können aber auch in
Kinos und da das ganze erst ab März
ausgegeben wird hat sich die Berliner
Landesregierung rot rot grün etwas ganz
anderes überlegt etwas ähnliches aber
schon früher denn am 12.02 wird er
gewählt also sollen die 18-Jährigen hier
in Berlin schon vorher ein extra
Gutschein bekommen eine extra
Kulturkarte mehr Meter 50 Euro noch mal
obendrauf quasi aber früher und mit
diesem mit dieser kulturkette sollen sie
aber auch zum Beispiel in Clubs wie wir
früher gesagt haben Diskus gehen können
also feiern tanzen auf Kosten der
Steuerzahler da sage ich ganz klar nein
denn wir wissen auch dieses Geld muss
irgendwann erwirtschaftet werden und der
Party Kater der kommt meistens nach der
Party in Form höherer Steuern deswegen
Schluss mit diesen Geschenken an unsere
jungen Leute die müssen lernen wie man
sich selbst das Feiern erwirtschaftet
und sollen nicht irgendwie ja zum Spaß
gezwungen werden das ist glaube ich der
falsche Weg aber gelächelt Herr
Friedrich ja 18-jähriges ich hätte die
50 Euro danken genommen und ab im Club
oder ist natürlich ich meine Geschenken
ja aber es ist wieder was ich vorhin
schon gesagt hat wir leben im
Sozialismus wir leben in der
Planwirtschaft deswegen ganz billiger
Stimmenfang man kauft sich die Stimmen
für die nächste Wahl und wir sehen immer
mehr dass der Staat immer mehr Geld
verteilt brot und Spiele ist das Thema
um die Bevölkerung bei Laune zu halten
wird auch eine Art Entschuldigung für
die Jugend sprechen während des
lockdowns und so weiter aber es ist wie
gesagt Sie haben es richtig gesagt ich
glaube jetzt weiß die Frau rot oder auch
die Regierung nicht dieses Geld muss ja
irgendwann erwirtschaftet werden weil
der Staat hat nichts zu verschenken
insgesamt also die müssen genau linke
Tasche rechte Tasche jeden muss klar
sein jedem Zuschauer natürlich auch hier
was der Staat verschenkt muss auch
einnehmen in Form von entweder steuern
oder halt neuen Schulden und für die
Schulden und Steuern haften wir das
heißt wir werden weitere Steuern sehen
Erhöhungen sehen Abgaben sehen und da
ist der ganz fleißig mit
Grundsteuerreform Zensus und so weiter
und dahin gehen ähm muss man einfach
sagen es ist wie gesagt an absolutität
nicht mehr zu überbieten wir haben so
gesprochen über die Entbehrungen gerade
für junge Leute für junge Erwachsene 50
€ jetzt mal damit die ihre Freiheit
einmal genießen können für einen Abend
vielleicht lang für zwei ja gute Idee
Grund grundsätzlich glaube ich wie sie
schon gesagt haben dass das ist ein als
Kompensation für die Entbehrungen
durchaus sein gewissen Sinn haben kann
und wahrscheinlich auch so gesehen hat
aber natürlich ist übrigens vor einer
größeren Perspektive sieht dass man dann
natürlich betrachten muss woher kommt
das Geld man kann den Leuten nicht
beibringen das ist alles nichts kostet
das ist alles umsonst und ich glaube das
sind wir auch in der coronazeit mit den
mit den Staatsausgaben mit der
staatsorgie die wir gesehen haben
deutlich hineingekommen und und das sind
Fortsetzungen natürlich davon wenn jetzt
in dem Fall mal die Jugendlichen davon
was haben ja würde ich sagen vielleicht
ist das wissen sie aber die müssen
natürlich das auch lernen das ist
erwirtschafte empfehlen an einige
Berliner Schultoiletten beispielsweise
ich könnte mir vorstellen dass die 8
Millionen wenn wir sagen da sollen die
Schüler oder die jungen Leute was von
haben dass diese 8 Millionen auch anders
gut investiert werden oder sei es iPad
was auch immer also wenn ich an Berliner
Schulen gehe habe ich einen Eindruck
dass dort die Digitalisierung das ober
Thema ist ich habe sanitären Anlagen
besonders gut ausgebaut und es gibt auch
noch ein paar andere Dinge Sprichwörter
und heilen Stühle und so weiter und so
fort von daher könnte ich mir vorstellen
diese 8 Millionen ein kleiner Betrag
zugegeben aber die werden anders auch
gut eingesetzt und ich glaube das ist
wichtig ist gerade für junge Leute zu
wissen dass man sich den Spaß auch
selbst erarbeiten muss vor allem wenn
man dann früh erwachsen ist und aus der
Abhängigkeit des Staates rauszukommen
das ist extrem wichtig und hier wird
genau das Gegenteil gefördert hier wird
diese der Staat gibt mir Mentalität
gefördert die ist falsch und ich ergänze
noch in digitale Infrastruktur also da
muss ich auch sagen auch in Bayern da
hat sich unglaublich wenig getan nämlich
in den Bereichen viele Möglichkeiten
viele Alternativen die sich hier an
dieser ja lebhaften Gesprächsrunde
auftun um dieses Geld acht Millionen
sind allein in der Hauptstadt zu
investieren wir hier an unserem Viertel
nach 80 schon da einige Vorschläge ich
bedanke mich ganz herzlich bei Ihnen
fürs zusehen ich bedanke mich ganz
herzlich hier bei meinen Gästen wir
sehen uns morgen wieder machen sie es
gut bis dann